you said yesterday that when it comes to
Illegal migration you've seen it come
down by more than 90 percent where did
that number come from it was I was
speaking he was telling us the number is
I hear you I'm about to answer
people I'm about to answer you or
something if you if The Dramatics could
come down just a little bit but The
Dramatics would come down a little bit
dramatic about asking a question about
okay I'm gonna answer so I was speaking
to the parolee program as you know the
president put in place a parolee program
to deal with uh to deal with certain
countries uh on on ways that we can
limit illegal migration and we have seen
the data has shown us that it has gone
down by more than 90 percent that was
what I was speaking no I'm we're gonna
go we're gonna move